[Musik]
Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München zur Verfügung gestellt – vielen Dank. Ich möchte
mit einer leichten Entschuldigung für meine Stimme beginnen, von der
ich hoffe, dass sie im Laufe der Zeit besser wird, aber
Sie wissen, dass ich bereits herzlich
willkommen geheißen wurde  und Honig und Zitrone, also habe ich mich
sehr gut um mich gekümmert, und es ist diese
Ehre und ein Privileg, hier zu sein und
Ihre Serie für Sie zu eröffnen. Vielen
Dank an Nina und Yang
und an Sie alle, dass Sie in einer
dunklen und frostigen Zeit herausgekommen sind  Der Abend ist vielleicht nicht frostig,
aber bald, so sagte Nina. Ich arbeite
seit drei Jahren an einem Buch, das
jetzt zum Glück fertig ist
und von meinem Schreibtisch, wenn es noch nicht im
Bücherregal steht, und das sich mit Schönheit
als ethischem Ideal befasst, also bringe
ich meine Arbeit zusammen  in Tugendtheorie und feministischer
Philosophie, also werde ich heute
über etwas sprechen, das ich in dem Buch nicht wirklich mache,
das aber aus den
Argumenten des Buches über den Aspekt der öffentlichen
Gesundheit von Schönheit stammt, und über das ich
sprechen werde  entstehende Schäden für andere
und die Pflichten der Politik  Ich mache etwas
, das ich in dem Buch überhaupt nicht tue, um zu
erkennen und vielleicht sogar darüber nachzudenken,
wie sie einige
dieser Schäden angehen könnten. Wenn es also um Schönheitsschäden geht, lag
der Fokus der politischen Entscheidungsträger und sehr
vieler Ethiker nur auf denen,
die  engagieren, und wie Nina sagte, beteiligen sich kaum
Philosophen an dieser Debatte, aber
diejenigen, die es tun, haben sich im Allgemeinen darauf konzentriert,
was wir als riskante
Praktiken betrachten könnten, also werde ich heute damit beginnen, zu
fragen, welche Schäden
standardmäßig als Themen in der Debatte anerkannt werden und
welche  nicht,
dann konzentriere ich mich auf die vernachlässigten
Schäden, die Schäden für andere, also Schäden für
diejenigen, die sich nicht engagieren oder nicht
maximal engagieren, so dass dies
im weitesten Sinne als Selbstverletzung angesehen
werden kann, da beide Eingriffe dem zugefügt werden
uns selbst direkt oder es ist etwas, das wir dafür
bezahlen, dass andere uns
zufügen, so dass Schäden an anderen normalerweise die
Art von Schäden sind, über die sich liberale Demokratien
am meisten Sorgen machen, während sie sich weniger
um den Schutz von Menschen sorgen f  Selbstverletzung,
weil dies als
beunruhigend paternalistisch angesehen wird, so dass
dieser ausschließliche Fokus auf die
Schädigung anderer durch politische Entscheidungsträger und
Akademiker sehr seltsam ist. Es ist ein ungewöhnliches und
verwirrendes Rätsel, also werde ich heute Abend
versuchen, einiges davon zu sprengen
und zu schauen  drei Schäden an anderen, einer
direkt und zwei indirekt, also erstens der
direkte Schaden an Anbietern von
Schönheitspraktiken, zweitens und indirekte, aber
spezifische Schäden an
heutigen Menschen, die abnormal sind, und ich werde
auf die Abnormalität zurückkommen, und drittens ein
indirekter und gemeinschaftlicher allgemeiner Schaden an
allen und mir  Abschließend schlage ich vor,
dass im Gegensatz zu aktuellen
Diskursen die am weitesten verbreiteten und
signifikantesten und wahrscheinlichsten Schäden nicht
diejenigen sind, die sich maximal
engagieren, sondern andere, und daher müssen
theoretische Arbeiten sowie Empfehlungen für Politik und
Praxis
diesen Vernachlässigten Aufmerksamkeit schenken  Schaden, wenn
sie vermeiden sollen, voreingenommene und
kontraproduktive Richtlinien und Praktiken zu befürworten
, bevor ich zu diesen har übergehe  ms an
andere Lassen Sie mich zunächst die Art und Weise diskutieren, in
der die Schäden der Schönheit
normalerweise zumindest in vorherrschenden ethischen
Diskursen und in den Diskursen der
politischen Entscheidungsträger konstruiert werden, sodass sich diese Diskurse hauptsächlich
auf diejenigen konzentrieren, die sich mit
Schönheitspraktiken und kosmetischen Verfahren befassen, so dass sich die
politischen Entscheidungsträger Sorgen machen  über Empfänger, die
sich riskanten Verfahren unterziehen, dass
Praktiker nicht richtig ausgebildet sind
und dass Verfahren in
unter regulierten oder völlig unregulierten
Räumlichkeiten stattfinden und dass ungetestete und gefährliche
Produkte verwendet werden und dass solche Sorgen
durch
Skandale und Bedenken hinsichtlich der öffentlichen Gesundheit unterstrichen werden, so dass
dies das Polyimplantat erbärmlich ist
Der Skandal von 2010, als
Brustimplantate fälschlicherweise aus industriellem
Silikon hergestellt wurden, begann in Frankreich und
breitete sich dann aus, und es gibt ähnliche Skandale
bei nicht-chirurgischen Verfahren, also Implantaten,
Botox und Injektionsmitteln
Horrorgeschichten über verpfuschte Abläufe oder
Lecks  Implantate und so weiter, also gibt es
erhebliche Schäden, die mit
Füllstoffen und Injektionsmitteln verbunden sind, also gehören dazu
Infektionen, Schwellungen, Blutgefäßblockaden,
Gewebetod, allergische
Reaktionen, verlängerte Schwellungen, Blutergüsse
und sogar Erblindung, und diese Art von
Skandal hat zu öffentlichem Aufschrei geführt, und
dem folgten Berichte und
Die im Vereinigten Königreich so prominentesten Empfehlungen
waren eine Überprüfung des Gesundheitsministeriums aus dem Jahr 2013
, die normalerweise nur als K
AAG-Bericht bezeichnet wird, und diese empfohlenen politischen
Empfehlungen, um diese Probleme
in drei Bereichen anzugehen, die zuerst bereitgestellt werden, sodass
sie besorgt sind, dass Produkte
sicher sind, und sie sind es  die Sorge um
die Verantwortung der Praktiker, zweitens
die Pflege, also hier die Sorge um
die Information und den Schutz der Öffentlichkeit
und drittens die Sorge, was Sie tun können,
wenn etwas schief geht, also wurde dies
von den
Berufsverbänden vorangetrieben, die Chirurgen regulieren,
also vom General  Medical Council
und dem Royal College of Surgeons und wie
ich es verstehe  Und es gibt
in Deutschland sehr ähnliche Codes, so wie
in Großbritannien können Botox und Füllstoffe keine
dauerhaften Füllstoffe sein, nur dauerhafte Füllstoffe
können nur von medizinischem Fachpersonal injiziert werden,
und in Deutschland wie in
Frankreich, aber nicht wie in Großbritannien
gibt es Gesetze darüber  was
beworben und beworben werden kann und was nicht
so irreführend oder andeutungsweise nachteilig sein
kann, kann nicht beworben werden und sehr wichtig:
Vorher-Nachher-Fotografieren sind
in Deutschland und Frankreich verboten, aber
in Großbritannien sehr lebendig und gut, aber
nicht-chirurgische Verfahren sind oft
riskanter als Operationen und  Diese sind jedoch weit
weniger reguliert, so dass Botox zum Beispiel
in Großbritannien in Deutschland verschreibungspflichtig ist,
aber es kann über das
Internet gekauft werden und wird
von Krankenschwestern, Kosmetikern und anderen häufig verwendet und geteilt, und nicht
dauerhafte Füllstoffe sind eine sehr graue Zone,
daher die chaotische Bewertung  einprägsam heißt es,
dass und das ist das Zitat in der Mitte,
dass eine Person nach einem nicht-chirurgischen kosmetischen
Eingriff keinen Schutz mehr hat und
redr  Weniger als jemand, der einen
Kugelschreiber oder eine Zahnbürste kauft, und so weiter,
Hautfüller sind ein besonderer Anlass
zur Sorge, da sich jeder als Arzt niederlassen kann, ohne dass
er eine
Ausbildung oder
Vorerfahrung oder andere ausreichende Kontrollen
in Bezug auf die Produktqualität benötigt
Die meisten Hautfüller haben nicht mehr
Kontrollen als eine Flasche für Reiniger.
Deutschland ist etwas besser reguliert,
aber wie gesagt, es ist eine sehr graue Zone, wenn
es um Dinge geht, die nicht
dauerhaft und nicht verschreibungspflichtig sind,
also habe ich zur Vorbereitung ein wenig nachgesehen
herum und ich fand im W Magazine und einem
schönen Interview alles, was Sie
Deutschlands besten Anti-Aging-Dermatologen schon immer fragen wollten,
der anscheinend genau
hier in München und vielleicht in diesem Raum ist,
also verschreibt er eine wirklich interessante
Mischung aus natürlichen Produkten, einschließlich
patentierter Firmen  aber auch die
Reinjektion des eigenen Blutes in die Kopfhaut die
Injektion von Vitaminen sowie
natürlich die kann man sicher nutzen  Sahne und
vielleicht etwas Hydrauliksäure oder vielleicht ein
bisschen Botox und sehr
interessanterweise haben wir anscheinend in Deutschland
mehr Füllstoffe
in den Vereinigten Staaten, weil es
lange dauert, bis die Füllstoffe von
der SDA in den USA und in Deutschland zugelassen werden
viel mehr Einspritzung verschiedener Arten
von Hydrauliksäuren jetzt, das ist sehr
ähnlich wie in Großbritannien, in Großbritannien sind wir viel
weniger geschützt als in den Vereinigten Staaten,
nur weil wir dies nicht als einen
großen Teil der Praxis betrachten, also ist es nur weniger
reguliert  Okay,
also genaue Daten, um genau zu sagen,
was von wem wem injiziert wird, sind
sehr schwer zu bekommen, aber was wir
wissen, ist, dass vor allem injizierbare
Medikamente dramatisch zunehmen, und Sie können dies nur
auf Selfies sehen, wenn Sie
sich die Lippen ansehen  ändern sich, also normalisiert sich das nicht
und es ist offensichtlich, aber wir haben nur
sehr wenige genaue Daten, so dass an einigen
Orten die Verwendung von Botox, nur um ein
Beispiel zu nennen, zur Routine wird und in den USA
wird als regelmäßige
Körperpflege wie Zähneputzen oder Haareschneiden beschrieben
, daher ist es nicht verwunderlich, dass
Politiker und Ethiker sich
Sorgen über die Schäden für diejenigen gemacht haben, die
sich an solchen Praktiken beteiligen, eine Reihe von körperlichen
und psychischen Schäden, und
es ist auch nicht verwunderlich, dass sie '  Wir haben uns
als professionelle Gremien auf diejenigen konzentriert,
die sich engagieren, weil sie die
Profis sind, die das Engagement durchführen, aber
der andere Grund und einer, der weitaus weniger
verständlich ist, ist, dass der Fokus teilweise darauf liegt, dass
es schwierig ist, die Schäden zu verfolgen,
wenn es um Schäden für diejenigen geht, die dies
nicht tun  Das Sammeln von Daten über diejenigen
, die sich engagieren, ist möglicherweise nicht vorhanden, aber es ist
viel weniger schwierig
, Daten über diejenigen zu sammeln, die sich nicht engagieren.
Wenn es also um Daten zu gemeinschaftlichen Schäden
geht, gibt es insbesondere keine kausalen Daten, also
gibt es keine Beweise für gemeinschaftlich  Schaden ist
nie kausal es erfordert die Verfolgung sozialer
Muster Trends Korrelationen machen
informiert, aber immer interpretativ oder
Schlussfolgerungen daraus d  In Anbetracht dessen sind
Behauptungen über Gemeinschaftsschäden schwerer zu
begründen und nie endgültig, so dass
körperliche Entstellung oder Schmerzen, die
direkt
durch eine Operation oder durch eine verpfuschte
Injektion verursacht wurden, etwas schief gelaufen
ist, Nebenwirkungen aufgetreten sind, der
Ursache leicht nachgegangen werden kann, im Gegensatz dazu, den Druck erhöhen
sich an mehr Schönheitspraktiken zu beteiligen,
ist wohl ein gemeinschaftlicher Schaden und
einer, der mit der zunehmenden
Nutzung der Normalisierung von Praktiken korreliert, aber
dies ist eine unbestimmte Beziehung, so dass
trotz des erheblichen Schadens, von dem wir
glauben, dass er auftreten kann, wenn er indirekt und
gemeinschaftlich ist, ein Mangel an direkten kausalen
Beweisen besteht  bedeutet, dass die
politischen Entscheidungsträger davor zurückschrecken
, solche Schäden zu erkennen und anzugehen, und dennoch ist
es die eigentliche Aufgabe der politischen Entscheidungsträger oder sollte es zumindest sein,
die Schäden in
ihren Zuständigkeitsbereichen zu berücksichtigen und das
Zusammenspiel von Praktiken, Richtlinien und
Normen als Aufgabe von Polymate-Entwicklern anzuerkennen
Als sehr allgemein angesehen wird die Einführung einer
Regelung, die drin
bleibt  Individuen den Raum, das Leben zu leben, das
sie wählen, solange sie erstens nicht
schaden und zweitens die Freiheit anderer nicht unangemessen einschränken,
und genau
in diesen Schäden an anderen in Schönheit sehen
wir die Einschränkung der Freiheit anderer
durch eine erhöhte
Aufmerksamkeit auf eine Beschäftigung mit Schönheitspraktiken zu
richten, damit die Schäden der Schönheit nicht
auf diejenigen beschränkt sind, die sich engagieren, und um
die Schäden genau zu betrachten, brauchen wir einen
viel breiteren Rahmen, der
Schäden für andere erkennen kann, die sich
aus einer zunehmenden Beschäftigung mit zukünftigen
Praktiken und dem Klopfen ergeben.  auf die Auswirkungen eines
solchen Engagements, da das Engagement
normalisiert wird und die Mindeststandards steigen,
so dass solche Schäden nicht nur für diejenigen entstehen,
die sich dafür entscheiden, sondern und vor allem
für diejenigen, die sich nicht oder nur
genug engagieren, um minimale Schönheitsstandards zu erfüllen,
sollte gut genug sein
normal zu sein, also bevor ich mich meinen drei
Schäden zuwende, lassen Sie mich klarstellen, dass dies
keine erschöpfte Liste der Schäden für andere ist
, die mit b verbunden sind  Viele andere Schäden, die
ich hätte über unsere allgemeinen
Schäden der Diskriminierung oder mangelnden
Möglichkeiten aus Gründen der Schönheit sprechen können,
also möchte ich diese nur erwähnen, weil
sie an verschiedenen Stellen viel Presse bekommen,
also zum Beispiel eine
Pyramidendiskriminierung oder ein Lookismus
ist  zunehmend gefordert und
mit Sexismus und Rassismus verglichen,
ist dies ein sehr umkämpfter Bereich, insbesondere
im Hinblick darauf, dass das
Aussehen nur einen Unterschied macht, z.
B. bei der Beschäftigung oder anderen
Möglichkeiten, sodass die empirischen Beweise
darauf hindeuten, dass es einen kleinen, aber sehr
deutlichen Vorteil gibt  zu gutem Aussehen und einem
kleinen, aber sehr deutlichen Nachteil,
als unattraktiv eingestuft zu werden, also gibt es eine
ziemliche Lücke zwischen dem unteren und dem
oberen Ende der Skala und es scheint, dass
Vor- und Nachteile für
eine Reihe von Bereichen gelten, von
Beziehungen über Bildung bis hin zu
Freundschaft  Gruppen behandeln Sie sogar damit, wie
gut Ihre Lehrer auf Sie reagieren und so
weiter, aber das ist ein großer Wettbewerb  d data
und andere argumentieren, dass solche
Vorteile überschätzt und durch die
Nachteile aufgewogen werden, die mit einer Überbetonung eines übertriebenen Aussehens einhergehen,
aber insgesamt nehmen die
Forderungen nach einer Regulierung des Aussehens zu,
insbesondere in einigen
demografischen Gruppen, und wir haben sicherlich
Beweise dafür, dass häufiger Menschen  haben das Gefühl,
dass sie sich in Schönheitspraxen engagieren müssen,
um nicht diskriminiert zu werden,
und immer mehr
Empfänger von Schönheitsoperationen sagen
uns, dass sie sich einer
Operation unterzogen haben, um sicherzustellen, dass sie
weiterhin beschäftigt werden und in
ähnlicher Weise beschäftigt werden können, wenn dies der Fall ist  dass
Schönheiten bedeutend sind und Gutes ermöglichen,
ähnlich wie Gesundheit oder Bildung,
dann ist ein Mangel an Schönheit oder ein fehlender Zugang
zu Schönheit möglicherweise ein Fall von
Ungerechtigkeit, wenn dies der Fall ist, dann wird die Verteilung von
Schönheitsmöglichkeiten für den Zugang zu Schönheit oder die
Entschädigung für einen Mangel an Schönheit zu einer
Angelegenheit  der Verteilungsgerechtigkeit nicht
anders als andere Güter der Gerechtigkeit,
also ist dies eine
tatsächliche  Ein ungewöhnliches Argument in Europa
klingt sehr seltsam, es ist tatsächlich der
vorherrschende öffentliche Diskurs in Brasilien,
wo das Recht auf Schönheit eine Standarddiskussion ist
, wo
Schönheitsoperationen verfügbar sind und
vom öffentlichen Gesundheitsdienst und öffentlichen
Krankenhäusern weitgehend bezahlt werden, eine Schlüsselleistung  was
sie geben ist plastische Chirurgie und in diesem
Zusammenhang soll den Armen ein
Recht auf Schönheit zugesprochen werden - und die allgemeine
Diskussion dreht sich darum, warum die Mai
dieses Recht nicht haben sollte, so sehr wie ihre
Herrin, jetzt gibt es allerlei
Dinge  worüber wir in
Frage und Antwort sprechen können, aber es ist sehr
wichtig zu erkennen, wo
diese Debatte stattfindet, da es sich um
ein normales und sehr reales Problem der öffentlichen Gesundheit handelt
, also habe ich nur diese beiden Schäden angesprochen,
eine über Lookism und
Diskriminierung  eine sehr lebendige Debatte in den USA
im Moment und eine über die ungerechte
Verteilung von Gütern oder Möglichkeiten,
nur um zu zeigen, wie teuer dies sein könnte,
wenn die Trends so weitergehen, wie sie sind,
so dass die Schäden, auf die wir uns heute konzentrieren
werden, eigentlich viel weniger umstritten sind als
diese beiden Schäden, und ich denke  viel
entscheidender, daher sind die drei von mir
ausgewählten Häuser sehr unterschiedliche Typen
und sie sollen als Beispiele für
Arten von Schäden dienen, um die Art von Schäden zu veranschaulichen
, die mit
Schönheit verbunden sein können, wenn wir sie
so weit wie möglich betrachten  Ziel ist es zu zeigen, dass
diese Arten von Schäden sehr
unterschiedlich sein können von denen, die auf engagierte
Personen fallen. Sie
treffen verschiedene Gruppen auf unterschiedliche Weise, aber
zusammengenommen sind sie teuer, also sind sie
auch entweder bereits gekrümmt oder treten möglicherweise auf
, aber wir haben nicht nachgesehen  für sie,
also wissen wir es nicht oder sie sind wahrscheinlich, also ist
das erste ein direkter Schaden für leicht
identifizierbare andere, das zweite kein
indirekter Schaden für ziemlich identifizierbare
andere und das dritte  d ist ein indirekter, aber
allgemeiner Schaden für die meisten, vielleicht alle, also
ist es zunächst ein Schaden für die Anbieter, so dass die meisten
Schönheitspraktiken, einschließlich sehr vieler
invasiver Praktiken, viele Ihrer
Injektionen nicht in
medizinischen Einrichtungen oder von
Ärzten durchgeführt werden und nicht medizinische
Einrichtungen viel weniger reguliert sind  als medizinische
Sektionseinstellungen und im Suchkontext
gibt es sehr viele Risiken sowohl für Anbieter
als auch für Empfänger, daher argumentiere ich in meinem Buch
, dass Schönheitsoperationen
besser als
Schönheitspraxis in einer Arztpraxis zu verstehen sind und dass
wir uns Schönheitspraktiken vorstellen sollten
existieren in dieser Art von Spektrum oder
Kontinuum, also haben wir am einen Ende unsere
sehr minimalen Pflegepraktiken wie
tägliches Haarbürsten, die Routine und die
tägliche Anwendung von Lotionen und Tränken,
und am anderen Ende haben wir die
riskanteste Art der Schönheitspraxis, die
Operation
In Anbetracht dessen, dass auch Operationen auf einem
Kontinuum stehen, so dass einige routinemäßig und
häufig sind, mit schnellen Genesungszeiten und
geringen Komplikationen  Raten und einige sind
komplex, neu und haben lange Genesungszeiten
mit hohem Komplikationsrisiko.
Das Beispiel, das ich
im Moment häufig verwende, ist der Unterschied zwischen
Brustimplantaten, die relativ
routinemäßig sind, und Gesäßimplantaten, die
entschieden nicht sind, und ich kann sprechen  mehr
dazu später, weil es irgendwie
faszinierend ist, aber das andere häufige Beispiel
für nicht routinemäßige Operationen in Bezug auf ihre
Komplikationen sind Bauchdeckenstraffungen, bei denen die
Komplikationen über 50% betragen und sie dennoch
so etwas wie eine Art Routine sind,
wenn Sie sich das vorstellen  Auf diese Weise
gibt es keine klare Grenze zwischen Verfahren,
die routinemäßige tägliche Schönheitspraktiken sind,
und invasiven oder chirurgischen Eingriffen, und
es gibt auch keine klare Grenze zwischen dem, wer
welche Praxis in welcher Umgebung ausführt,
und in der Mitte dieses
Kontinuums sind die Dinge
besonders grau und  Undurchsichtig Sehr viele
Schönheitspraktiken werden einfach nicht
von hochqualifizierten privilegierten und
geschützten medizinischen Fachkräften durchgeführt, und selbst
wenn sie es sind  Sehr oft sind diese medizinischen
Fachkräfte nicht speziell
in diesen Verfahren ausgebildet, so dass zum
Beispiel sehr viele
injizierbare Medikamente von Krankenschwestern von
in anderen Bereichen ausgebildeten Ärzten verabreicht wurden, und in Großbritannien sind
Zahnärzte
als besonders lukrative Ergänzung in diesen wachsenden Markt eingetreten
Einige Schönheitspraktiken bergen ein
geringes oder kein Risiko und andere sind sehr
riskant, aber es gibt praktisch keine Arbeit zu
diesen Risiken für Anbieter, daher möchte ich mich
auf Anbieter konzentrieren, die in
nicht-medizinischen Umgebungen am am wenigsten
invasiven Ende des Kontinuums von Schönheitspraktiken arbeiten,
also dem Friseur  sind
Nageltechniker und Kosmetikerinnen, also sind
Kosmetikerinnen nicht hochqualifiziert oder
zumindest wird ihre Qualifikationsbasis nicht
als gleichwertig angesehen
oder nähert sich den medizinischen
Fachkräften an. In vielen Fällen
ist tatsächlich eine umfassende Ausbildung und Akkreditierung erforderlich, um bestimmte
Linien zu verwenden oder  Produkte von Geräten und wir
neigen dazu, ihre Fachkenntnisse zu unterschätzen,
aber sie  werden wahrscheinlich nicht
als Fachleute angesehen, insbesondere im
Vergleich zu Ärzten. Sie werden
als Dienstleister der unteren Preisklasse eingestuft, also
als ähnlich wie Ladenarbeiter oder Einzelhandelsmitarbeiter angesehen
, die ein Produkt oder eine Dienstleistung verkaufen, die
nicht zu den Berufsklassen gehört,
daher ist dieser Status  Bedeutungsvoll in
Bezug auf die Machtdynamik der
Beziehung zwischen Anbieter und
Empfänger, so dass der Schönheitschirurg eine
starke Krebskleidung hat, die Grenze erklärt
und sich letztendlich weigert,
eine Operation durchzuführen,
im Gegensatz dazu wird von der Schönheitstherapeutin
erwartet, dass sie das liefert, was der Kunde
wünscht, und solange sie beraten
kann  schlagen vor und es ist letztendlich
der Wunsch des Kunden, der sich durchsetzt, so dass die
Macht beim Empfänger liegt, der
Verbraucher und die Rolle des Anbieters besteht darin
, die Wünsche der Empfänger zu erfüllen, was es den
Anbietern erschwert, zu kontrollieren, was sie
tun, einschließlich des Umfangs, in dem
sie mit einem anderen Minister zusammenarbeiten  riskante
Produkte, daher gibt es Ausnahmen und
Gegenbeispiele für Promi-
Frisuren  Es ist sehr gefragt, sie können
viel Geld verlangen und sie können
wählen, was ihre Kunden Haare haben.
Ebenso können einige Chirurgen in sehr
gefährdeten Positionen sein, also haben wir viel
über Siegel-Chirurgen gesprochen, das sind Chirurgen
aus Ländern mit niedrigerem Einkommen, die
geflogen werden  eine Reihe von Operationen
schnell hintereinander
durchzuführen, so
dass sie die Menschen, die sie operieren, nicht vorher treffen. Sie
haben wenig Kontrolle darüber, wen sie
operieren oder wie viele Operationen
sie durchführen und so weiter und sogar die meisten
Experten und professionelle Chirurgen
fühlen sich möglicherweise unter dem Druck, das zu liefern oder zu versuchen
, das zu liefern, was der Empfänger verlangt, daher wurde
mir von sehr vielen Schönheitschirurgen gesagt,
dass sie manchmal einer Operation zustimmen,
nur weil sie wissen, dass
die Person so verzweifelt ist, dass sie sich
operieren lässt.  Sie gehen einfach zu
jemand anderem und das wird viel
schlimmer für sie sein, aber ich denke, das ist
ziemlich selten für die meisten,
die in Schönheitsfachleuten arbeiten a  Am
unteren Ende des Spektrums haben sie die
Kontrolle darüber gelassen, was sie liefern können,
sie haben weniger soziales und wirtschaftliches
Kapital und sie haben weniger Macht in der
Beziehung zwischen dem Anbieter und
dem Empfänger, angesichts des relativ
geringen Werts, der solchen Schönheitsarbeiten
beigemessen wird  Sie befinden sich oft in einem
stark wettbewerbsorientierten Umfeld, das
anfällig dafür ist, vom Markt verdrängt zu werden,
und sie sind schlecht bezahlt und haben einen niedrigen
Status. Sie können keine
bessere Bezahlung und
weniger schädliche und riskante
Arbeitsbedingungen verlangen oder sich selbst bieten, wenn wir uns also Nageltechniker ansehen
Sie erleiden körperliche Schäden
durch die tägliche Arbeit mit giftigen Chemikalien
und insbesondere durch das
Einatmen des Staubs, der beim Feilen von
Acryl- und Naturnägeln entsteht, so dass
die New York Times vor zwei Jahren einen
Bericht über die Bedingungen der
in New York arbeitenden Nageltechniker veröffentlichte
Artikel dokumentierten die Erfahrungen von
Frauen, die in Nagelstudios arbeiten, und sie sind
fast alle Frauen und die verursachten Krankheiten
durch die Chemikalien und Materialien, die
in Acrylnägeln und Gelpolitur enthalten sind, so dass die
Schäden, die die Frauen berichteten, entweder
erlitten oder sich dessen bewusst waren,
Fehlgeburten, Krebs, Hautreizungen,
Atemprobleme enthielten. Sie berichteten auch,
dass Kinder häufig mit
gesundheitlichen Problemen und Lernschwierigkeiten geboren werden,
also natürlich solche  Berichte sind nicht
evidenzbasiert. Diese Bedingungen, die
Frauen erlebt haben, wurden berichtet, dass
andere sie erlebt haben, wurden nicht verifiziert und
konnten auch nicht direkt mit den Arbeitsbedingungen gleichgesetzt werden, es
sei denn, wir führen
weitere Untersuchungen durch, aber wir müssen keine
weiteren Untersuchungen durchführen, um zu wissen, dass einige  von
den Chemikalien, die sie routinemäßig
verwenden, sind dafür bekannt, dass sie Krebs verursachen, andere
wurden auch mit
Fehlgeburten und anderen Schäden
für die reproduktive Gesundheit in Verbindung gebracht, so dass diese Arbeit der
Grundstein für riskante Schäden ist, die nicht auf Nageltechniker beschränkt sind.
Es gibt Hinweise
darauf, dass Friseure laufen  Risiken
durch häufigen Kontakt mit giftigen
Chemikalien  s und sie entwickeln
Hautallergien, Hautirritationen
und leiden schließlich an Atemwegs-
und Hauterkrankungen, so dass die
Eingriffe zumindest in einigen
Schönheitspraxen direkt sind und
selten erwähnt werden. Dafür gibt es zahlreiche
Gründe, nicht zuletzt den Fokus auf
Schönheitsoperationen  Isoliert auf andere
Schönheitspraxen hat die Debatte oft verzerrt, was
bedeutet, dass Anbieter
einfach als relativ privilegierte und
mächtige Personen wie Chirurgen angesehen werden, und aus
offensichtlichen Gründen sind Chirurgen viel weniger
anfällig für Schäden als der Friseur
oder der Nageltechniker, dennoch schaden diese
Anbieter  eine direkte und fast völlig
fehlende Debatte über die Schäden
der Schönheit, und doch sind sie direkt
auf die zunehmende Bedeutung zurückzuführen,
die dem Aussehen beigemessen wird, die Beschäftigung mit
einer sich normalisierenden und
normalisierenden Praxis und das Aufkommen
minimaler Schönheitsstandards wie
gepflegter Nägel  Wie vielerorts werden
Dinge wie Haarfärbemittel schon seit Jahren zur
Norm  Wenn die
zum Erreichen des Normalzustands erforderliche Mindestanforderung nicht erfüllt wird, wird die
Zahl der direkt Geschädigten
steigen und es werden Maßnahmen erforderlich sein,
so dass ich zum ersten Mal den
Anbieter direkt schädige, mein zweiter Schaden für andere
indirekt ist, aber einer
bestimmten Gruppe von Personen zufällt  zumindest einigermaßen
identifizierbare Personen, obwohl
genau, wer in diese Gruppe fällt,
offen für einige Debatten ist, so dass die
fragliche Gruppe diejenigen sind, die
sich nicht an minimale Schönheitsnormen halten oder nicht anpassen können,
also aus Personen bestehen, die
deutlich außerhalb dessen liegen, was als
normal angesehen wird  in dieser Gruppe haben es offensichtlich
versäumt, Schönheitsstandards zu erfüllen, und zwar auf eine
Weise, die die meisten Menschen nicht erfüllen, so dass
sie es nicht versäumen, sich zu messen, weil
sie alt übergewichtig oder behaart sind, was
alles daran liegen könnte, dass sie die Standards für das
Aussehen nicht erfüllen, aber auf eine Weise,
die es sein kann  angesprochen oder die
allgemein normal erfahren sind, so dass diejenigen in
der Gruppe, über die ich spreche, offensichtlich
unumstritten und vielleicht
dauerhaft sind  Sie fallen oft außerhalb des normalen
Bereichs und können als anormal bezeichnet werden,
und ich verwende diese Begriffe normal und
anormal ungern, aber sehr
bewusst und sehr bewusst, weil dies
die Art von Dingen ist, die auf dem Spiel steht, wenn
Standards für das Erscheinungsbild so stark in den Vordergrund treten, wie
dies der Fall ist  Kennzeichnungen, die
wir am Ende tun oder schlimmer noch nicht tun werden,
werden nur so tun, als würden wir es nicht tun, also
verwende ich diese Begriffe,
um die Bedeutung des potenziellen Schadens hervorzuheben, über den
wir sprechen, um zu
zeigen, wie ernst die Risiken sind  sind, die
an die Einengung des Normalen in einem Kontext anhaften, in
dem das Aussehen zunehmend
geschätzt wird, so dass diejenigen, die in diese Gruppe fallen,
diejenigen sind, die entweder bei der
Geburt oder durch einen Unfall entstellt wurden oder deren
körperliche Merkmale dramatisch
außerhalb des normalen Bereichs liegen, also worauf es
ankommt  dass es keine Möglichkeit gibt,
Mindeststandards zu erreichen, und das
ist auffallend der Fall, also ist dies ein
kürzlich erschienener Bericht, der von einer Wohltätigkeitsorganisation namens
Changing Faces The Directo stammt  r, dem
ich kürzlich mit einer Ehre gedient habe, sich mit
sich ändernden Schönheitsstandards zu
befassen, und sein besonderes Anliegen ist es, wie
Standards des normalen Aufstiegs, was mit
denen passiert, die bereits unter allen
Arten von Diskriminierung leiden, also ist meine Behauptung hier,
dass diejenigen, die lange fallen  weit
außerhalb des Normalbereichs
sichtbarer und
damit verletzlicher werden, da Schönheit
wichtiger wird und die Mindeststandards steigen,
so dass die Schäden, die diese Gruppe
erleiden könnte, sehr allgemein und bezeichnenderweise
unsere Häuser in Bezug auf das Selbstverständnis der
Identität einschließlich geringer sind
Selbstwertgefühl und erhöhte Scham-
und Angstgefühle Schäden durch erhöhte Stigmatisierung
und Diskriminierung und Schäden durch
Ausgrenzung, da die Darstellung und Kommunikation der Eltern zunehmend von Bedeutung ist.
Soziale Ausgrenzung wird zu einer
realen Möglichkeit für diejenigen,
die die Erscheinungsnormen der digitalen
Welt nicht erfüllen können  fühlen sich einfach
unwohl mit Kommunikation, die
eher bildbasiert ist  r als
textbasiert und da die Teilnahme
an virtuellen bildbasierten Plattformen wächst und gemocht wird,
könnte das Erreichen von Pyramidenschwellen zu einer besonders
effektiven Voraussetzung für soziale
Interaktion werden, so dass beide Behauptungen
erstens, dass diese Gruppe
unterschiedlicher und sichtbarer sein wird, und zweitens, dass
sie es sein werden  durch
diesen erhöhten Unterschied in der Sichtbarkeit geschädigt werden,
sind sie offen für Kritik und vermitteln
empirische Kritik. Lassen Sie mich also
zuerst die Einengung des Normalen
und zweitens, warum dies für diese Gruppe schädlich sein könnte,
also zuerst die Einengung
des Normalen, dass mehr  zurückgezogen wird, um
minimale Schönheitshaltungen zu erreichen, um gut
genug zu sein, um normal zu sein, dies ist ein Argument
, das ich ausführlich und über eine ganze
Reihe von Kapiteln in meinem kürzlich erscheinenden,
nicht kürzlich für mich erschienenen
Buch vorbringe, also kurz gesagt, ich behaupte, dass es
immer mehr ist  von mehr von uns verlangt wird
, um das zu erreichen, was heute als
minimale Erscheinungsbildstandards angesehen wird, und dass
dies sehr schrittweise geschieht
sehr sanft Ich spreche darüber, dass es heimlich geschieht,
also sehen wir mit sehr wenig Diskussion und mit sehr
wenig Kritik in kurzer Zeit
ziemlich dramatische Veränderungen, also betrachte ich
besonders das routinemäßige Ende des
Spektrums, also schaue ich auf die Körperhaarentfernung, die
wir haben  Innerhalb einer Generation hat sich sichtbare
Körperbehaarung von akzeptabel, sogar sexy, zu
inakzeptabel, beschämend und anormal entwickelt, und vor
zehn Jahren gilt dieser Trend der sichtbaren
Körperbehaarung zunehmend auch für
Schamhaare, insbesondere in der
angloamerikanischen Welt, aber zunehmend auch
über eine andere Praxis hinaus  will nur
gelegentlich, aber es wird jetzt oft
als erforderlich angesehen, insbesondere für
Frauen, aber in vielen demografischen Gruppen ist es für Männer
, die Haare zu machen, so dass die meisten Frauen über einem
bestimmten Alter an sehr vielen Orten
ihre Haare färben und graue Haare zu einem
Trend für die Jugend werden  Es ist
besonders anstrengend, graue Haare zu bekommen
und weniger für die Alten, so wie die
Zunahme von Nagelstangen, die
in sehr ma zu einer erforderlichen Übung wird
Ich denke, Sie wissen, dass ich
oft sage, wenn ich in Deutschland spreche,
dass Deutschland auf dieser Kurve ganz unten
und Brasilien ganz oben ist und dann
viele andere Orte in der Mitte liegen
Ich bin mir sehr bewusst, dass das nicht ganz so
vertraut ist, aber ich hatte einen Studenten, der
kürzlich Nagelstudios in einer halben
Meile von London gezählt hat, wo das vor fünf
Jahren eines war, jetzt gibt es 40, weil
es etwas wird, das Frauen
routinemäßig machen und so  Holz war nicht
etwas, was wir uns vorgestellt hatten, also ist es eine Art
allmähliche Veränderung, die die Leute nicht
bemerken, die dann plötzlich zu einer
Anforderung wird, also ist es in einigen Demografien
schon weit darüber hinaus, also
werden Botox und Füllstoffe in manchen Kreisen
als vorbeugend angesehen
Behandlung, so dass Frauen, die so
jung wie Studenten sind, anfangen,
sich routinemäßig mit präventiven kosmetischen Botox-
Operationen zu befassen, ist immer noch außergewöhnlich,
und wenn Sie sich die Proportionen ansehen,
können wir unmöglich sagen, dass dies in den meisten
Bevölkerungsgruppen i  Es ist erforderlich, aber
es wird zunehmend normalisiert und
zunehmend gewünscht, sodass die allmähliche
Eskalation von Mindeststandards in Verbindung
mit einem erhöhten Druck, sich
über das hinaus zu engagieren,
zu einer Einengung dessen führt, was
als normal angesehen wird, sodass diejenigen, die
sich engagieren können, immer
anspruchsvoller bleiben  Standards Die Gruppe, von der ich
hier spreche, diese anormale Gruppe,
sie wird mehr auffallen,
sichtbarer sein, unterschiedlicher sein und sie werden vielleicht
auch nur seltener, also je mehr
Dinge wir tun können, um Dinge zu reparieren, desto mehr
können wir Menschen verändern als die  Es werden immer
seltener diejenigen, die wir nicht ändern können, also
reparieren wir zunehmend Dinge,
die repariert werden können, unabhängig davon, ob
sie sich auf unser Funktionieren auswirken, also gibt
es viele Beispiele dafür, vielleicht ist
das klassische Beispiel die abstehenden
Ohren, die jetzt routinemäßig sind  behoben das
hat nichts mit der gesundheit zu tun
es ändert nichts am hören okay und das
ist routinemäßig wir routinemäßig wenn wir
muttermale und oth entfernen können  er
Gesichtsverunstaltungen und wir
begradigen routinemäßig Zähne, und das ist eine schmerzhafte und
invasive Arbeit, und dennoch tun wir es
jetzt gelegentlich bei unseren Kindern, dies sind
funktionierende Regionen, Überbiss oder Plaquebildung,
aber größtenteils ist es nur aus
Gründen des Aussehens, und Sie wissen, wenn Sie
über die Veränderung nachdenken  Was
als akzeptable oder normale Zähne angesehen wird,
und den Unterschied zwischen europäischen
Zähnen und amerikanischen Zähnen, Sie werden feststellen, dass sich
diese Standards ändern, wenn Sie sich
Austin Powers mit Witzen darüber ansehen, wie
Sie in den 60ern
mit solchen schiefen Zähnen wieder ein Sexsymbol sein könnten
Sitten ändern sich gut, also ist es neben
der Fixierung von Anomalien
zunehmend so, dass das Aussehen
als Grund für die vorgeburtliche
Auswahl angesehen wird, sei es eine
genetische Präimplantationsdiagnostik
oder eine vorgeburtliche Untersuchung mit anschließendem
Schwangerschaftsabbruch
Lippen- oder Gaumenspalten sind klein,
solche Abbrüche kommen vor und dies
aus optischen Gründen  Die
Funktion eines Gaumens oder einer Lippe kann leicht
durch eine Operation korrigiert werden, aber die verräterischen
Anzeichen bleiben oft bestehen, so dass solche Merkmale
Entstellungen sind, und da das Aussehen
wichtiger ist, werden sie als
signifikant und signifikant genug angesehen,
um eine Beendigung zu rechtfertigen, so dass dies darauf hindeutet,
dass das Aussehen zwar komplex ist  Dies ist ein
Faktor bei der Auswahl und vielleicht einer, der im
Laufe der Zeit wichtiger werden könnte.
In einer kürzlich durchgeführten Studie
berichteten die Teilnehmer, dass 11% der Paare
sagten, dass sie einen Fötus gekauft hätten,
wenn er für Fettleibigkeit prädisponiert wäre, also
möchte ich das nicht  Bei unseren
Diskussionen darüber, ob wir einem Kind, das nie existiert, Schaden zuzufügen oder nicht, erneut zu gewinnen
, ist das nicht meine bevorzugte
philosophische Entscheidung, aber ich möchte
darauf hinweisen, dass eine erhöhte Selektion
diejenigen in der normalen Kategorie seltener,
sichtbarer und anfälliger für Schaden macht, so dass dies angesichts
dieser Trends nicht der Fall ist  Es ist unvernünftig zu
glauben, dass diejenigen, die außerhalb des
normalen Bereichs liegen, sichtbarer
und seltener werden, aber selbst für den Po selten sind
Int der Anomalie ist nicht unbedingt
ein Schaden, was mich zu meinem zweiten Argument bringt,
aber um zu argumentieren, dass solche
Personen anfälliger dafür sind oder sein
werden, geschädigt zu werden, bedarf es etwas mehr, es
erfordert einige Beweise, die wir nicht
wirklich haben, also gibt es zwei
Möglichkeiten  ist, dass diejenigen, die
sehr sichtbare Persönlichkeiten sind und in diese Gruppe fallen,
tatsächlich einigen der steigenden Forderungen entkommen könnten,
so dass nach dem
Aktivismus für Behindertenrechte des letzten
halben Jahrhunderts eine solche
Diskriminierung jetzt nicht nur illegal ist,
sondern auch missbilligt wird  Es ist
inakzeptabel, dass wir einen
Kulturwandel hatten, daher kann es sein, dass Begriffe der
Diskriminierung, Stigmatisierung und Scham
für diese Gruppe als einfach
inakzeptabel angesehen werden,
so ironischerweise könnte es sein, dass diejenigen, die
weit außerhalb des normalen Bereichs liegen,
sich als weniger anfällig erweisen könnten  zu schaden als
der Rest von uns, die ihm näher kommen, aber
auf der anderen Seite und sicherlich einige
der Menschen, mit denen ich in wechselnden
Phasen gesprochen habe, sind sie tatsächlich  Sie
haben eigentlich beide Ansichten, aber eine ganze
Reihe von ihnen fühlen sich verletzlicher als
sie es taten, selbst wenn sie älter werden, wenn sie
sich normalerweise weniger verletzlich fühlen sollten, so dass
es auch vernünftig ist zu glauben, dass das
Aussehen wichtiger ist als diejenigen, die es nicht
tun  Die Qualität des Aussehens wird
dies als weiteren Kostenfaktor empfinden. Wenn also die Erfüllung von Schönheitsidealen im
Laufe der Zeit zu
einem zunehmend
geschätzten Aspekt der persönlichen Identität und zu einem
Schlüsselfaktor des Selbstwertgefühls
wird, wird es
in Bezug auf die Identität zunehmend kostspieliger, diese Kriterien nicht erfüllen zu können
und Selbstverständnis sowie
die Kosten dafür tragen, in der Öffentlichkeit geschätzt zu
werden und auf andere Güter zugreifen zu können
, bis zum Arbeitsplatz zurück, so dass
wir nicht genau wissen, wie solche Schäden entstehen,
weil wir nicht nach
Beweisen dafür suchen, sondern danach  Diese Gruppe
ist sichtbarer, das ist bereits klar der
Fall, also müssen wir jetzt
erkennen, dass es nicht
unvernünftig sein könnte, zu glauben, dass es
zu Schäden kommen könnte a  Damit verbunden, und wir müssen
dies erkennen und ihm etwas
Aufmerksamkeit schenken, damit meine zweite Gruppe mein
dritter und letzter Schaden ist, ist der indirekte
Schaden für alle steigenden Standards und die
zunehmende Beschäftigung mit
Schönheitspraktiken, da mehr von uns verlangt wird
und zu kurz kommt  immer mehr von uns scheitern und dies
führt wohl zu einer zunehmend toxischen
Umgebung, die den
allgemeinen Schaden für alle darstellt, so dass steigende
Mindeststandards nicht nur denen schaden,
die solche Standards niemals erfüllen können, sondern wenn das
Engagement zunimmt, wird Nicht-
Engagement ungewöhnlich und
schließlich für alle  hat die Gefahr
, in einige dieser abnormalen
Kategorien zu fallen, also sind
die Worte von Susan Bardo, dass der gewöhnliche
Körper zum defekten Körper wird, sodass
der behaarte Körper und das nicht gefärbte Haar
jetzt oft als abnormal angesehen werden. Sie haben
das Zitat von der Frau in der Studie gesehen
Über Körperbehaarung Körperbehaarung wird
zunehmend als unnatürlich und
anormal angesehen und das sind die Worte,
die für so etwas verwendet werden
Es ist klar, dass die Auswahl im Laufe der Zeit nicht so
überwältigend ist. Die Auswahlmöglichkeiten sind einige, die
schließlich dazu führen, dass alle weniger
Auswahlmöglichkeiten haben, sich nicht zu engagieren. Daher gehen die Auswahlmöglichkeiten davon aus, dass sich
die Auswahlmöglichkeiten insgesamt allmählich verringern. Daher
verfolge ich in dem Buch die Mindeststandards
, die auf Frauen unabhängig vom
Beginn des Berufsdrucks zutreffen  So jung
wie 3, so haben wir Dreijährige sehr
wohl bewusst das dünne Ideal
wollen etwas an ihrem Aussehen
ändern Tugenden zu dünnen Silhouetten
Hinweise auf die Silhouetten, die sie
bis ins hohe Alter in Zeiten von
Krankheit und Schwangerschaft wieder Bereiche, die
verwendet werden  geschützt werden und junge Mädchen werden
zunehmend gelähmt durch eine Epidemie von
Körperbildangst und es ist eine weltweite
Epidemie, zusätzlich wird Schönheits- und
Körperarbeit zunehmend von Männern verrichtet und sowohl Männer
als auch Frauen leiden unter
Körperbildangst und Aussehensideale werden
immer schwieriger  für Männer zu erreichen, wie
sie es für Frauen seit langem sind,
entsprechend für alle unabhängig vom
Geschlecht, was zu erreichen ist
Die Mindeststandards für Schönheit, um gut genug zu sein
, steigen und es gibt Kosten für das
Scheitern, nicht zuletzt das Gefühl, ein Versager zu sein,
so dass die Schäden, die mit Körperangst verbunden
sind, unzählige sind. Dazu gehören Schäden durch
körperliche Unzufriedenheit, es gibt
geteilte und gemeinschaftliche Schäden durch Zeit,
Geld und Mühe  Zeit, die
Schönheitsprodukten gewidmet wird, wird nicht
anderen Waren gewidmet, also Standard-Opportunitätskosten-
Argumente, und wenn Sie sich die
Kosten, die Größe und das Geld ansehen, die mit dem
Schönheitsgeschäft verbunden sind, ist dies ein viel größeres
Geschäft als viele andere Sektoren des
internationalen Handels und es gibt  Schäden
durch eine zunehmend toxische Umgebung,
so dass es, wie ich bereits sagte,
besonders schwierig ist, die
Ursachen für diese Zunahme der
Körperbildangst zu verfolgen, aber aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
ist es jetzt so, dass die
Körperbildangst als die drittgrößte und
schädlichste bezeichnet wird  Herausforderung, vor der junge Menschen
heute in Großbritannien stehen, nämlich nach der Beschäftigung
und dem Scheitern des Erfolgs im
Bildungssystem, das ich ihr gerade gegeben habe  Jede
Seite mit Statistiken aus der jährlichen
Einstellungsumfrage bei Mädchen, also sprechen diese
für sich selbst.
38 % der Mädchen zwischen 7 und 10 denken, dass
sie nicht protune sind. 91 % der
Mädchen zwischen 17 und 21
sollte
zumindest manchmal abnehmen denke ich - 80 %
der Mädchen zwischen 17 und 21 53 % der Mädchen
zwischen 7 und 10 denken, dass sie
zumindest manchmal perfekt sein müssen steigend auf 84
Prozent der Mädchen zwischen 17 und 21 und
der Anstieg des Körperbildes  Angst ist auch
global, zieht Essstörungen auf
der ganzen Welt an und sie manifestieren sich
in verschiedenen Kulturen unterschiedlich, aber der Aufstieg eines
dünnen Ideals und der Aufstieg von
Essstörungen ist überall klar, es ist jetzt so
, dass junge Männer etwa 1/3 der
Essstörungen junge Männer sind  und so weiter,
also spricht diese Art für sich selbst.
Es ist nicht unverschämt zu sagen, dass dies eine
Epidemie der Körperbildangst ist, und obwohl
es nicht möglich ist, das Ausmaß zu verfolgen, in
dem Faktoren dazu beitragen, ist
dies zweifellos der Fall  ly und
unumstrittenes Aussehen
immer mehr an Bedeutung gewinnt, besonders für
junge Menschen, und dass dies einige
ernsthaft schädliche Auswirkungen hat, haben wir
zunehmend ein toxisches Umfeld, in dem
das Aussehen dominante
Schönheitsoperationen normalisiert werden und
Schönheit als Schlüssel zur persönlichen
Identität angesehen wird, was individuelles Scheitern und
Erfolg bedeutet, so My  Ich behaupte nicht, dass gemeinschaftliche
Schäden die einzigen Schäden sind, die von Bedeutung sind,
weil sie
beeinflussen, was für
Individuen möglich ist, und ich habe mich auf die
Schädigung anderer konzentriert und argumentiert, dass wir
den Rahmen verschieben sollten, um
diese vernachlässigten Schäden in aktuellen
Diskursen anzuerkennen  Diejenigen von politischen Entscheidungsträgern,
Ethikern und Anwälten, die diese
Art von Schaden ignorieren und sich nur auf Schäden konzentrieren,
um sich darauf einzulassen, fehlen meiner Meinung nach beklagenswert,
da es sehr viele Schäden für andere gibt, und
diese werden derzeit einfach aus
dem Diskurs gestrichen, also habe ich drei Beispiele gegeben,
aber wie ich es besprochen habe
Diskriminierung könnte es also noch viel mehr geben, was
politische Entscheidungsträger antreiben sollten  Die
Bedeutung des Schadens kann nicht die Art des
Schadens sein, also die derzeitige
Prävalenz von Körperbildangst
, wie sie insbesondere, aber
nicht nur von jungen Menschen erlebt wird, und ihre
negativen Auswirkungen und negativen Auswirkungen
umfassen erhöhte Angst, geringes
Selbstwertgefühl, verringertes Selbstwertgefühl  körperliche Aktivität
verringert soziales und bildungsbezogenes Engagement
usw. Dies hat jetzt epidemische
Ausmaße. Wenn wir also diese
Art von Schaden auf eine körperliche Ursache zurückführen könnten, also
beispielsweise wenn es
während der Visite eine neue Freizeitdroge oder einen neuen
Schadstoff gäbe, würden wir dies sofort tun
auf ein solches Medikament abzielen, also ist das klassische
Beispiel dafür, wie wir die Konstruktion verschieben,
das Beispiel über die Schäden des
Rauchens.
Nachdem das Rauchen als nur
individuell angesehen wurde, machen wir uns Sorgen um das
individuelle Engagement, aber es ist ihre
Freiheit und Wahl, aber jetzt betrachten wir es
voll und ganz  als ein Problem der öffentlichen Gesundheit,
also wenn Schönheitsschäden wie die, die ich besprochen habe
, als ein
Problem der öffentlichen Gesundheit angesehen wurden, aber ich denke sicherlich, dass die
ep  Idemie unter den Krankheiten sollte dann die
Politik sein, die wir entwickeln würden,
um dies anzugehen, wäre sehr unterschiedlich, also ist
es sicher viel schwieriger, soziale Ursachen
anzusprechen und gemeinschaftliche Schäden anzugehen,
als den Konsum von Substanzen zu verbieten, und
selbst da sind wir nicht sehr effektiv
dass uns die Schwierigkeiten beim Umgang mit den
Schäden jedoch nicht davon abhalten sollten
, die Schäden zu erkennen, und dass sich die Politik darauf
konzentrieren sollte, die größten Schäden zu erkennen und dann zu sehen,
ob Sie etwas tun können,
um die größten Schäden anzugehen, und nicht
darauf, was am einfachsten zu
beheben ist, also zu ignorieren oder zu vernachlässigen  die
Schäden für andere, ob sie indirekt
oder direkt sind, führen zu einem verzerrten und falschen
Bild und verschleiern das Ausmaß, in
dem sich dies ändert und diese
signifikanten und neu auftretenden Schäden
individuell wirksam sind